man in charge of America's drug war he
made history when he was announced the
first physician ever to serve in that
role it comes at a time when this
country is battling an extraordinary
crisis and American dies every five
minutes by overdose on this broadcast
we've gone inside prisons and to our
Southern border to see what's happening
this week we went to Washington
the estimate is that the overdose crisis
costs us 1.5 trillion a year which is
equal to the GDP of Russia correct so
we're losing that amount of money
Raul Gupta was born in India but raised
in Maryland
as a doctor he's seen addiction patients
recover and he's attended funerals of
those who did not
after running West Virginia's public
health Bureau and working for the March
of Dimes he became director of The
Office of national drug policy control
you're the first physician
to serve in this role what message do
you hope that sends well I know that the
Methodist census that this is a public
health crisis that the nation is in
doing as Gupta told us gone are the days
when the root of the drug Scourge was
found in poppy fields and on farms
today it's a chemical World especially
when it comes to fentanyl something
President Biden discussed this week at a
summit of North American leaders in
Mexico today we've discussed how all
three of us can continue to deepen and
strengthen our shared efforts to cut off
the flow of illegal fentanyl including
by tackling the precursor chemicals used
in synthetic drugs so many of these
precursors are for fentanyl are coming
from China why can't more be done to
limit the amount coming in from China
well that's exactly what we're doing
from day one it's it's still coming in
though a lot well what we want to do is
make sure that we are working with the
People's Republic of China or PRC uh to
make sure that they are holding
accountable the Bad actors within China
that are shipping but we also want to
make sure that we know what's coming in
before it gets here that is not
happening to a level that it's
acceptable to me at this point and
that's exactly why we're continuing to
push them to do more it's the bigger
problem the Bad actors in China who are
selling the precursors or is it the the
drug dealers and the cartels in Mexico
who are using those precursors to
manufacture
I think Jeff what you just highlighted
is the global imprint of this problem
but Gupta says he's focused not just on
Supply but demand and what's called harm
reduction that means not waiting until
people ask for help but instead bringing
it to them we meet them where they are
as opposed to expecting them and I say
this as a physician to come to my office
or my place because oftentimes it's too
late and you cannot treat a dead person
the bite Administration has not rejected
the controversial idea of expanding safe
injection sites where people can legally
use drugs legislation remains tied up in
courts the Administration has openly
pushed for drug treatment programs
inside prisons
but it's also not changed the standing
of gupta's job
for the past 13 years the drug czar has
not been given the clout to speak
regularly with the president or sit at
cabinet meetings President Obama demoted
this position from cabinet level
are you hoping that your boss right now
re-elevates it to cabinet level I come
to work every day and I focus on
everything that I can do every single
day to help Americans out there make
sure that they're doing they're living
longer they're being able to have safer
and healthier communities as such and
that's where my focus remains is that a
yes or a no well I'm going to continue
to do what the American people want us
to do with just to make sure that we're
working hard to end the opiate crisis
and I'm going to keep doing that lately
there has been some better news new data
released this week shows overdose deaths
that surge during the pandemic have
declined slightly for five straight
months we certainly feel confident that
there seems to be a light at the end of
the tunnel meaning that we've now seen
about two and a quarter percent
reduction from from the peak of Overdose
deaths that's about 2500 people but
think about it like a large ship you you
can't just turn it around you've got to
slow down and then it takes time to turn
that around
the question is whether that dip becomes
a long-term Trend or whether it's just a
temporary thing but overdose is now the
leading cause of death for Americans age
18 to 45. wow I think one of the most
interesting things that he said to me is
the idea that you got to meet people
where they are that there are all of
these problems what can you do in the
here and now and part of that is meeting
them where they are to try to solve the
problem here not just worry of the
others as he said as a doctor I can't
treat a dead person wow and then if
there's this like understanding within
those users and many of us know people
who use even things like marijuana they
think it's safe and with these new
um
fentanyl being manufactured in certain
drugs that people thought at one time
were safe hey it's it's it's it's it's a
wide open Horizon a lot of this is just
fentanyl being used by itself but it it
does happen yeah